and george carlin uh
at the end of his life when he was doing
standing yeah he switched his point of
view to everything is falling apart so
i'm just going to enjoy watching it yeah
i'm going to root for it and it was a
very weird point of view and at the time
people were split about it i loved it
but he just said very clearly we have
[ __ ] up the world we've [ __ ] up the
earth we're being cruel to each other
the human race is a [ __ ] show i think he
said when you're born into the human
race you you're you get a ticket to the
freak show and when you're born in
america you get a front row seat right
and his whole thing was i'm just going
to love it and i think the bit i
remember it's starting with is yeah when
you go see a car race
how you like root for uh
the crash that he's rooting for like the
end of the human race yeah and he would
do these long bits where he would
explain how much he loves when
things are on fire and accidents and
uh
and i
have to say as i'm 54 i'm beginning to
slide into that point of view